Chưa mới làm tháng 18, nha có hội, sự thích có hội trên thành bẫn đã sự lễ tiếp nhận tắt phần nghệ thuật điều khác an sáng,
sự mạnh của lòng dân, gió nghệ nhân buổi văn tự, chào tạm bảo tạng có hội Việt Nam.
Tắt phẩm sự mạnh của lòng dân, cao mừng nhìn chiến tranh 1 mi so mươi li thề hiện lâm tổ chức cuộc tổng tuyền cửa đầu tiên.
Dọng tạm buổi sáng vi mết, giấu mốc khi niệm tạm mi năm có hội Việt Nam,
tắt phẩm được kiến tạo với hiện tượng tạm chim lại bay xem lên mây, biểu chương trò mùi tạm đời của hồng,
cộng hồn thương liên của giân tộc Việt Nam.
Ở vị trí chung tâm là có quý nước cộng hòa sả hội chủ nghĩa Việt Nam,
bử tưởng của sức mạnh đại đàn kết xanh tộc của độc lập tự gió và chủ quyền Quốc gia.
Bự tiếp nhận và chương bài tắt phẩm không chỉ có phần làm phong phủ thêm giả chị hiện vật,
nâng cao tràn nghiệm của công chúng mà còn khẳng định tinh thành giến chủ,
nềm tinh của nhân dân đự vực khu khội, tôn phíng giả chị đại đoàn kết xanh tộc.